let's have a look at the first to see if
we're okay with them and then I won't
during the last two with you does that
sound reasonable yeah okay so hands up
number one who gives a thumbs up to the
outside hands up straight who's happy
with it
okay bastard I do you think your hands
now can we just note what did he do what
to register on the very first line of
his working what whether these numbers
come from
yeah right yeah okay so he's got the
denominators be able to play that's
where fifteen comes from and then he
multiplies their numerators and that's
where the 24 comes from okay
important to note it's a little bit
different to getting a common
denominator we'll look at that over here
he's combining two fractions together
then what happens how do you get from
this line to this line what's that about
someone else sort of is the F doesn't he
is yeah what's the word Dicey's wicked
boy did some into it yeah I guess he's
actually done two things at once which
is slightly sneaky but if we're okay
with it if it's right that's okay he has
simplified right cuz you notice that
fractions denominator has changed cheers
that it changed her 15 into a five what
did he do to the top of the bottom to do
that yes Breann he's divided by three so
that turns into a five which turns 24
into an 24 divided by 3 it's tiny it's
an eighth and then he saw the second
thing 8 over 5
that's only what's that called again
start with an eye and even copy fraction
he's converted to a big steamer ok
thumbs up by the way another 500 won all
right what about number 2 that was much
harder because of the denominator you
doing something different what's
happened on this first line any
suggestions yes straight this one yep
35 on 21 + 54 21 that right go read it
quickly yeah
this one looks like a 54 to be so 54
right I will point out here right if you
guys are wondering about this then don't
you think a teacher will wonder if they
look at your paper it is not entirely
clear I think that's pretty close to a 4
especially when you look at that 9 see
that quite different again two things
have happened
number one is a conversion here from a
mixed dual to a and then secondly what
was the second thing that happened what
happens do not it change yesterday
yeah good commented on it oh this one
got x 7 + 7 this one got x + 3 3 + 3 3
right 3 times 18 is 54
3 times 7 is 21 again can I just point
out everyone looks like we got some
right answers here while on both this
question in on this question it is very
tempting to do lots of things at once
just be really really careful more
things you do at once it's a little bit
like fizz anyone ever okay try to carry
lots of lots of things and then you just
end up dropping someone on the floor
it's just where we make mistakes when
that kind of thing happens right so I
would have avoided doing it as much as
possible he's putting together is
simplified okay can you will pick up
with me question 3 let's do this
together there's a division of fractions
right and it's currently a mixed numeral
because here is a bit hard to work with
so what should I do with this mixing
rule yeah good I'm gonna convert it so
now I've got 10 divided by if you
haven't done this yet I'm going to 3
times 2 which is 6 over 3 and a 1 on 3
that's 7 on 3 6 + 1
ok dividing by a fraction now
underneath so when I divide by a
fraction what do I do if I'm like
dividing by 1/2
that's how many cards are there in there
what can I do here yeah very good so you
might remember we established this is
kind of cool we saw a pattern right we
saw if you say something like this right
that's like how many Hobbs out there in
ten which is just like saying if you
double ten you'll find out how many plus
they're wrong so that's why you see
we've multiplied and taking the
reciprocal which is exactly what I've
got here okay very good
if I just change this division into
multiplication right then I've changed
this entire you mean answer this
question yeah yeah this yeah okay so
what would we do with this what we what
would happen okay here's what happens I
get this yeah
now by that I will point out this is
correct but it's a key fractions are
hard to do with the last thing I want to
do if I can avoid it I will is to do
with fractions on top of fractions it
just ends up being confusing okay so
what I'm trying to do is take a strategy
to make it easier to solve it is the
reason why yeah the reason why is
because division and multiplication are
in the same family of operations they do
the same kind of thing right if you do
this with the multi-nation you can also
do it with division but you have to be
careful and I'm totally encourage you to
do this I think it's a much less
error-prone way
what yes it is but if what you're
dividing by is like a confusing number
like I'm divided by thirds here right
I think dividing by thirds is harder
than multiplying by 3 we're super good
at multiplying yeah so I'm gonna take
advantage of that moment which I'll
finish this off
this is 37 that's fine you can change it
to a mixed movie if you like but I give
that a thumbtack okay
all right what's the last question it
was three take away something right
three take away one and I literally
cover him up why did you get so good
okay now question yes or answer yeah
okay okay fantastic now there's a really
quick easy way to see this right and
maybe you want to draw this along with
me whenever you can get a picture
whenever whenever whenever you can okay
so watch this if I draw three bars you
see me do this before right to signify
this guy I'm gonna divide them all into
fits like this like so it'd be great if
you follow along with me okay so you can
see here this is my three right why do I
have to do is I'm about to take away 1
and 2/5 okay so let's see how much I'm
going to subtract I'm gonna subtract 1
that's this whole thing and then I'm
also going to subtract 2/5
that's this much of it see that's two of
my blocks so you can see what's left
right Brad now the first time here is
one and here is three minutes three of
those blocks okay why don't three fits
you don't
yeah you could we looked at conversions
before dinner we two-fifths as a decimal
would be easy
sorry what a TV this would be one point
one point four okay and you can check
them in the calculator or you could turn
this into 4 over 10 which is also point
4 and that'll give you 1 point 6 which
is also okay now we know all these
different kinds of ways to that's a
great question I would always do a
question in the style that the question
is given me so if they gave it to me as
fractions I would deal with it as
fractions and if they gave it to me as
decimals I would hand it back to this
decimal you can convince between them
and sometimes one form is clearly better
than another but if you aren't sure just
deal with whatever there okay probably
if you've done correctly okay unless of
course they asked you to put it in such
and such a form and then they were be
able to do something